dans ce cimetière de rio de janeiro
cette scène se répète des dizaines de
fois par jour au cours des dernières 24
heures 1500 24 personnes sont mortes
ducobu 19 dans le pays soit le 2e nombre
le plus élevé depuis le début de la
pandémie
j'étais à l'hôpital et les personnes
présentant des symptômes du coït 19
arrivées tout le temps tout le temps
cela ne peut pas être nié j'ai vu cela
l'hôpital de mes propres yeux
depuis novembre le brésil est touché de
plein fouet par une deuxième vague de
contamination
une seconde vague aggravée par les
rassemblements liés aux fêtes de fin
d'année le seuil des 200 milles morts
vient d'être dépassé pas de quoi
vraiment faire fléchir jaillir ball
sonar ou pour qui l'économie reste
prioritaire nous sommes en deuil
aujourd'hui nous franchissons le seuil
des 200 mille morts
il ne sert à rien de continuer cette
vieille histoire de rester à la maison
et l'économie on verra plus tard
cela ne fonctionnera pas ça sera le cas
au brésil et cela peut conduire à des
conditions encore plus dramatique que
les conséquences du virus
nous ne pouvons pas devenir un pays
pauvre un pays de chômeurs sans pib et
avec des dettes
nous regrettons les morts mais la vie
continue petite lueur d'espoir pour les
brésiliens
après plusieurs semaines de suspense et
de reports le vaccin koronova du
laboratoire sinovac est efficace à au
moins 78 % selon le gouvernement de sao
paulo partenaires de l'entreprise
chinoise
joão doria le gouverneur de l'état
assure d'ailleurs que la vaccination
débutera le 25 janvier prochain après
validation par l' agence de vigilance
sanitaire une crise sanitaire aux
conséquences sociales désastreuses au
début du mois le gouvernement confronté
à un déficit public un sou tna bhl a dû
mettre fin aux aides d'urgence versées
aux 68 millions de brésiliens les plus
pauvres soit un tiers de la population